the surgeon will perform
glaucoma surgery to fix drainage problems
in the eye due to high intraocular pressure
the anterior chamber fills with a
watery fluid called aqueous humor that
bathes and nourishes the cornea and lens
as aqueous humor flows from the chamber
posterior continuously drains
through the trabecular meshwork between the iris and
cornea adequate flow of
aqueous humor keeps the pressure inside the
eye normally balanced
when glaucoma occurs
aqueous humor drains out too slowly
or is produced too quickly
causing accumulation  of the fluid
that increases intraocular pressure
with attention to this pressure the
optic nerve fibers become damaged
and eventually die which can lead
to permanent vision loss
glaucoma surgery options
include laser and non-laser
procedures the procedure  usually lasts
between 10 and 60 minutes
if you have the procedure the l  You
will be seated with your face
facing the laser machine. You will be
given eye drops to
numb your eye. A small device will be placed
in your eyes to hold
your eyelids open.
A trabeculoplasty is a
laser procedure that increases the drainage of fluid
from the trabecular meshwork.  during a
laser trabeculoplasty the doctor will use
a special contact lens held
over the front of the eye to focus a
beam of laser light on the trabecular meshwork
if the procedure is successful this will
allow more fluid to flow out of the eye
which will lower intraocular pressure
a peripheral eye is a
laser procedure that opens a
narrow or closed drainage angle between the
cornea and the iris this closed angle
interferes with fluid drainage in
this procedure
the doctor will use the laser to
make a small hole in the
iris  which will allow the fluid to flow
more freely within the eye
the photocoag cycle  ulation is a
laser procedure that reduces the
production of aqueous humor
in the photocoagulation cycle the doctor
will use a laser to destroy parts of
the ciliary body that produce
aqueous humor if successful it will reduce
fluid production and lower
eye pressure
a trabe colectomy is  an
incision surgery that removes a part of the
eye's trabecular meshwork during this
procedure
the doctor will use small
instruments to remove tiny
pieces of tissue from the wall of the eye,
leaving a small hole through
which aqueous humor can drain
out and be  reabsorbed into the bloodstream
although medications and
surgical treatments may help
prevent future vision loss they
cannot repair vision lost
due to glaucoma after the
procedure you will be monitored
for an hour or two before
leaving you will be fitted with a
eye patch or bandages to wear temporarily
you will be prescribed go
your doctor will probably advise you to keep your eye
dry for a while avoid swimming or
bathing and temporarily stop driving
lifting weights or straining